in today's IT world most developers were
many different hats and you're probably
no exception but managing applications
designed for different platforms can be
quite a chore the problem is it's hard
to handle all the architecture and
upkeep required to do such a task for
example dealing with your own
provisioning not to mention all the work
to ensure that everything is secure what
if you could wrap your workloads in a
common package like docker containers
that you can run on Prem and in any
major cloud thankfully this is exactly
what Google cloud run is for cloud run
is a fully managed service compute
platform it automatically scales and
load balances your stateless containers
on a paper request basis so you can do
what matters most build great
applications it's driven by portable
docker base images that can run almost
anywhere letting you leverage the best
of what you need in the cloud
containerization lets you have full
control over your runtime environment
without giving up the benefits of
serverless whether you're a pro at
containers or looking to build your
first containerized app cloud run lets
you get your code into production in
seconds simply run a g-cloud command to
deploy your stateless container and
cloud run will do the rest
listen to requests and events pass them
to your code and scale them up and down
to meet user demand the best part you
can do all of this in your favorite
language and you only pay for the
requests that you process cloud run is a
great solution for running your
containerized a qdp applications if you
don't have specialized to have ops
requirements but why stop there
cloud run can be used to help multiple
kinds of workloads not just HTTP base
ones let's take a closer look at what
you can do if Club run the first major
use case for cloud run is event
orchestration cloud run has the ability
to listen to events from other cloud
components handle web hooks and manage
distributing events and workloads other
components
this built-in ability makes it
straightforward for your application to
handle complex event needs another good
set of workloads for cloud run involves
data processing when you need to ingest
and transform large amounts of data
cloud run provides an infrastructure
your workloads need to handle auto
scaling authorization and event triggers
via a pub/sub model of communication
cloud run leverages the power of Google
cloud to provide these features for you
so you can build complex scalable data
pipelines while saving time spent on
back-end confusion of course this type
of flexibility also makes building
micro-services and developing api's a
lot easier simply configure your
stateless container to listen for and
handle HTTP requests web hooks or cloud
events and you've got the ability to
deploy a Federation of micro services in
no time advanced features such as
traffic splitting audit logging and
custom domains are built-in for when you
need them and with the power of Google
clouds client api's and cloud workflows
cloud run becomes a powerful tool to
help you automate complex processes that
require coordination of distributed
services and api's like G suite or
Google clouds ml and AI offerings if
you're looking to build a mobile or
web-based application that you know how
important a fast development cycle and
native local host developer experience
our cloud run makes creating client-side
front-end services easy and seamlessly
interfaces of storage databases and
other services on the backend all the
same power scalability and demand
regardless of your traffic profile so
whether you're a seasoned IT
professional or just discovering the
flexibility of container based workloads
cloud run is right there to help you
build great portable applications for
more information check out the links in
the description below and don't forget
to subscribe to our cloud youtube
channel for more great content on
building your application
you